herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
in dem wir heute nicht minecraft spielen
sondern dass das camp bestimmt einige
von euch dabei geht es darum dass man
errät welcher begriff welches thema mehr
gegoogelt wird und dann kommt teilweise
sehr sehr merkwürdige dinge raus
deswegen starten wir sofort wir haben
hier home depot das heim im depot gegen
bad weilbach weise es mit biermarken
amerikanische deswegen tausendprozentig
wurde bat weise auf die google übrigens
sie da unten links man highscore 17 im
spiel was ich jetzt nicht so schlecht
findet hätte spielt noch nicht so oft
gespielt aber die mal die ich gespielt
haben so vor drei monaten also so
schlecht da habe ich ungefähr so wie
durchschnitt vielleicht ein oder zwei
richtig gemacht ich bin ich auf die 17
schon im kreis drauf da bin ich froh
drum rum wahlweise auf ich auf jeden
fall
okay okay du bist etwas verlassen sich
frustrierend belegen den pornos girl
with the pearl ring michel perin und
netflix
was könnte wo lauter gejubelt werden
mädchen mit einem packen perlenohrring
mit 40.000 suchanfragen im monat oder
netflix mit flix
ja ich halte 68 millionen der rund
40.000 widget ist laura safe alter
schwede 6 millionen locker höher
okay leute lassen sich ablenken
discrimination oder star wars
starbucks ich habe glaube ich auch so
das gefühl dass so begriffe die ein
bisschen negativ sind sowie
discrimination oder eis oder wurden
nicht so oft wie google scheint das
heißt rafael nadal
nein jawoll der pepsi max es mehr warum
sie alter kann ich sein dass pepsi so
selten google wird es pepsi patches
früher fertig mit cola und pepsi light
ich geiler als cola light das team auf
jeden fall sein
judo gegen islamophobie islamophobie
also angst vor dem islam
ich habe vor bis auf dem negativer
begriff ich dass der winter wirbelt ja
seht ihr leute die negativen begriffe
werden sehr selten google argentiner
argentinien locker höher
selbst mein ganzes land als potter-fan
ehrung coca cola mehr
das war aber knapp alter cricket ich
weiß nicht cricket ist bei uns in europa
so klitzekleiner wenn indien ist das
richtig groß wie bayern linien deswegen
weil sich das anliegen des kritischen
gebissen nationalsport deswegen aber in
gen ist gigantisch dem über eine
milliarde einwohner aber dem kein
internet geht es kann man jetzt noch
nicht sagen keine ahnung es könnte alles
sein es kann auch sein dass von 6
millionen
ja showdown an alle inder würde es geht
raus home business wie gesagt negative
begriffe wenig aufgeholt locker locker
niedriger und top score 5c milan mehr
locker alter schwede 12 2 millionen-etat
richtig oft als ob exakt gleich viel
erzählt hat mich gesehen weiter als
kurzer zehn millionen mercury
also merkur niemals in new york mehr als
eine halbe millionen bis 1000 mal höher
cristiano ronaldo co host of ten
facebook facebook.com play sions aber
sechs millionen mal
ich weiß nicht ich würde fast sagen
facebook gehöre aber ich werde dich
zerstören facebook compilation wie
gesagt das einzige was sein könnte
ich sag ja news corp dessen ostens
choreo in der top ten of players share
on social das zu suchen ten noch mal zu
knacken
das heute noch schaffen denn sie war gut
dann können auch aufhören frankreich auf
jeden fall höher
thailand ist höher würde ich sagen weil
er so viele urlaub machen
dabei ist die vielleicht nicht android
seien deshalb in breslau oder sowie city
das ist natürlich sagt er das ist wieder
so eine negative sachen business wire
chicago cubs 183 millionen baseball team
aus chicago
tom und jerry meyer sein nfl auf jeden
fall mehr
ja sie muhammad ali hat auch viel aber
ich würde sagen weniger krass alter das
war richtig knapp japan weniger ja wohl
der lost weniger ja den 15 potato
petters was ich habe von dem ding noch
nie in meinem leben
es ist ein lauer lauer lauerte pack mal
mein gepäck man hat mehr als 12.000
aller suchanfragen monaten würde ich
sagen ja
fucking 5 millionen bradley cooper ahern
zum bau aller kriege ich die augen land
und der der keckem und bradley cooper s
lok aus und traun sparen oder alle
weiblichen zuschauer gibt zu ich bin
nicht so drin im wissen etwas trauen
schwärme angeht und so aber bradley
cooper ist wahrscheinlich weit vorn
dabei ja ja
bradley cooper 5 millionen nein
jawoll digger mit seiner google die
kleinen spitz mit salat mehr würde ich
sagen die undertaker jetzt weniger der
weniger bitte bitte bitte bitte
oh ja wir haben zehn games klacken
ruhiger jerman
was sollte ich wollte einfach nur die
elf packen müsste sie so schwer machen
wer zur hölle
es ist schon irgendwie youtuber aber
werden youtuber so oft gegoogelt hat
komm schon kommt schon kommt schon kommt
schon ja wohl egal
untersteller hat mir ja alter ist up
effekt gab es so was wie der dfb pokal
in england als im pokal zwischen fußball
mannschaften sängern der feier locker
alter schwede das war klos gleichstand
zwischen der weltcup-winter stella machu
picchu das ist diese als theken statt
nein laune ist es wieder so negative
bedürfen negativer begriff die werden
nicht so auf google aber lohnen das
glaube ich schon
wenn man sie nachts vor seinem pc sitzt
und denkt
deswegen hat mir
werden den highscore knacken können foto
schepp of the days video denke für
watching abfährt
was der termin bekommen entfernt